yeah where all the Rivera he was on the
ground in Puerto Rico covered in the
devastation there for over a week and
just a few hours ago he caught up with
President Trump while he was touring the
damage for an exclusive interview you
will only see tonight right here on
Hannity let's watch this then we'll come
back to Vegas obviously with the
President of the United States thank you
thank you for coming I'm sorry is seeing
the island under these circumstances
many people feared that because of the
awful tragedy in Vegas you would be
diverted you came anyway why well
they're special people and as you know I
know many people from Puerto Rico I come
from a place called New York and I love
the Puerto Rican people I also know the
island very well I've been here many
times and we have to help and we've done
a fantastic job this was a very tough
one you know I say we got an a-plus in
Texas we got an a-plus in Florida and we
may have done our best work here but it
hasn't been appreciated but actually if
you see over the last couple of days now
people are really seeing what we've done
the runways are open the ships are
pouring in and a lot of things are
happening so it's great on that note if
not being appreciated I noticed the
mayor of San Juan
you know you leaned in the crouch is the
probable Democratic candidate for
governor in 2020 she did not applaud
welcome to the bitter partisan politics
of Puerto Rico how do you feel you've
been blamed for everything from kids
dying to a cholera epidemic that didn't
exist well I don't know the mayor but
she was very very nice at the very
beginning she said it's incredible what
happened and all of a sudden I noticed
she went a little bit on the nasty side
and I said I guess she's running for
office and it turns out I was right she
isn't that a shock but I will say your
current governor he is done he's been
amazing
your congresswoman has been absolutely
amazing and the people I met your state
senators and lots of other people and
they've been so thankful and I think
virtually every mayor has been so
thanked I've met many of them this
morning the job we've done and it's the
job of the Navy and the
me and the Air Force the Marines the
whole thing I mean it's incredible the
US Coast Guard what they've done I mean
the lives that they've saved just so the
people are really very thankful battered
by two historic storms that wiped out a
power grid that was already antiquated
poorly maintained corruptly managed what
do you do
you had the Marshall Plan rebuilt Europe
after World War two well we see a trump
plan to rebuild this poor island well
we're gonna help the people you know
look this had a lot of problems and a
lot of debt they had 72 billion in debt
before the hurricanes hit and they had a
power plant that didn't work before the
hurricane so we're gonna help them we're
gonna do something and we're gonna get
it back on its feet but I'm just very
very proud of the fact that you know if
you look at just one statistic 16 deaths
that's a lot of this far too many deaths
but 16 if you look at Katrina they had
in the thousands and this was a storm
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
and you know we had FEMA here before the
storm even came they were on the island
during the storm and they were on the
island before the first storm you got
hit by two hurricanes so we're very
proud of the job we've done very very
proud and now we'll have to try and get
them back the power is slowly getting on
and the roads are open the runways are
open so these people that you've met
today all of the different people first
responders these are incredible people I
totally agree and it's been so
impressive to see the message to the
Puerto Rican people though to what
extent do you commit to help rebuild
this this matter place well we're gonna
work something out we have to look at
their whole debt structure you know they
owe a lot of money to your friends on
Wall Street and we're gonna have to wipe
that out that's gonna have to be you
know you can say goodbye to that I don't
know if it's Goldman Sachs but whoever
it is you can wave goodbye to that we
have to do something about because there
the debt was massive on the island
and my aunt Ella he doesn't care about
that she wants in helping too she wants
to hear from you we are going to help
the people out we're gonna get the
electric going again you know that was a
complete wipeout that wasn't like a
couple of poles came down that was
generating plants that was a lot of a
lot of very valuable equipment but it
was equipment in bad shape but we're
gonna put it in good shape I really
appreciate it thank you mister thank you
very much you've been a great friend
thank you all right now live with more
with exclusive interview with the
president in Puerto Rico our friend Fox
News correspondent at-large Geraldo
Rivera Geraldo here's my main question
for you there 15,000 people on the
ground between the military and FEMA and
all these government workers they
pre-positioned food water medicine
supplies the Navy was there we got top
military commanders from Afghanistan and
Iraq there I mean pretty unbelievable
stuff by the way like my hairdo and and
the attack by only one mayor got picked
up by everybody and it wasn't true what
did the president say about that
you know the he obviously is is hurt by
that it is very frustrating I have to
add one melancholy note though Shaun we
heard just minutes before we went on the
air that the official death toll has
risen from 16 to 34 and that is that is
tragic what I would just like people to
understand is blame Hurricane Maria for
those deaths don't blame President Trump
he really is trying it is very
frustrating endeavor the supply chain in
Puerto Rico it's a thousand miles away
it's a very difficult and logistically
challenging operation and you are
dealing with a dysfunctional government
that really gave bad information to FEMA
to begin with the power plants for
example are not damaged it is the power
lines that are down you know I think
that we'll get this done and the
president going there today I think was
really important although I'm really
proud of you you were on the ground for
what I think eight seven eight nine days
I promised you on Twitter I'm gonna
match the dollar than ten eleven days
well right I'm sorry I don't but I was
watching you
out of you I'll match you dollar for
dollar Samaritan's Purse whatever you
like done and congratulations on the
exclusive with the president thank you
for sharing it with us we appreciate it
Thanks all right